we got the news that Rahul Gandhi has
been disqualified as Member of
Parliament a day after he was sentenced
for two years for making comments four
years ago at an election rally narahul
Gandhi is the de facto face of India's
opposition so this is you know big news
here in addition to that he's also
someone who has led a lot of the
criticism against prime minister
Narendra Modi he has accused Modi of
crony capitalism and a sort of favoring
certain business houses for lucrative
contracts he's also led the criticism on
minority rights the issue of minority
rights in India now as of now as far as
the court case is concerned uh Gandhi is
out on bail he has about 30 days and his
team will be appealing that decision in
a higher court right now his party that
is the congress party has been
protesting over here actually on these
grounds a few a few minutes ago some of
those MPS have been detained by the
police they're also asking for an
appointment with the president saying
that the bharti janta party the
governing party has been targeting
opposition leaders by misusing a central
investigative agencies